وفي مخيم شعفاط بالقدس المحتله اصيب شعب
فلسطينيا فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا
من مخيم شعفاط في القدس المحتله مراسلنا
سمير ابو شماله سمير اذن اقتحامات وقتل
وجرح وهدم والمزيد من المستوطنات
تشهده الساحه الفلسطينيه منذ بدايه هذا
العام تحديدا ومع دخول الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده في سده الحكم في
اسرائيل نحن نشهد تصاعد كبير وواسع في
عمليات الدهم والقتل والاعتقالات وايضا
هدم البيوت الفلسطينيه همم قبل ان نتحدث
عن ما يجري في شعفاطات هناك بعض المصادر
المحليه همم في همم فلسطين تتحدث عن همم
ربما استشهاد فتى فلسطين همم متاثرا
بجروحه همم اصيب بها في مواجهات وقعت في
همم مخيم شعفاط للاجئين في شرقيه مدينه
القدس المحتله ولكن نحن ننتظر تاكيد من
الجهات الرسميه وتحديدا وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه بشان هذا الملف ولكن في مخيم
شعفاطعه في الساعه الاخيره انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه من ضاحيه السلام
الواقعه في مخيم شعفاط وبلتي عناتا
بالتحديد شرقيه القدس المحتله بعد ان همم
اكملت وانهت الهدم الداخلي ل همم شقه
الشهيد عدي التميمي منفذ هجوم حاجز شعفاط
العسكري وايضا اا مدخل مع علي ادوميم في
شرقي القدس المحتله في شهر اكتوبر بتشرين
الثاني الماضي والذي ادى ذلك الى مقتل
مجنده اسرائيليه واصابه احد حراس الامن
بجروح وصفات بالخطيره في حينه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقتحم هذه الضاحيه بمئات
الجنود مما يعرف بجنود حرس الحدود السابع
الاسرائيليه وقد حاصر المنطقه وقد اعتلى
هذه البنايه العسكريه وايضا المنازل
المجاوره وقد اقتحم الشقه السكنيه الخاصه
بعائله الشهيد عدي التميمي وقامت بهدم
الجدران الداخليه وتخريب ما يمكن تخريبه
في هذه الشقه وايضا تشميع الباب الرئي
للشقه وذلك لمنع العائله من استخدامه في
مره اخرى بعد هذا اليوم وبالتالي هذه
العمليه التي همم استهدفت مخيم شعفاط ايضا
تزامنت مع عمليات هدم قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في مدن اخرى من
الضفه الغربيه كمدينه اريحا وايضا الخليله
الذي التي هدمت خلال قوات الاحتلال اكثر
من 6 منازل وغرف زراعيه بحجه عدم الترخيص
حسب المزاعم الحكومه الاسرائيليه وايضا
كان هناك استهداف وقتل شاب فلسطيني عنده
مدخل مستوطنه كادوميم الواقعه على اراضي
محافظه قلقيليه وذلك بزعم انه كان يحاول
طعن احد الجنود الاسرائيلي وقد اطلق النار
عليه جنديه الايطالي وقد قتله في المكان
على الفاروق وبالتالي باستشهاد الشاب عمار
لحلوح عند قلقيليه اليوم ترتفع حصيله
الشهداء في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وتحديدها
في الضفه الغربيه الى 19
اذا بينهم اربعه اطفال وكان هناك ايضا
حملات اعتقالا في مدن المتفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه والقدس المحتله همم طالت اكثر من
16 فلسطينيه وبالتالي هناك اعتقال ل 300
اكثر من 300 فلسطينيه منذ بدايه هذا العام
وهذا يدلل ويشير على مدى تصاعد هذه
الوتيره من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والاجهزه الامنيه باتجاه الفلسطينيين وهذا
التصعيد من اليمين المتطرف اتجاه
الفلسطينيين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه سواء
بعمليات الاعتقال او القتل او هذه البيوت
الغربيه بشكل عام ايضا في القدس المحتله
شكرا لك سمير ابو شماليه مراسلنا من
شعفاط في القدس